c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche parce que parce que dans la
vie on entend beaucoup de contraire à ce
qui peut se passer dans la réalité
donc je pense que c'est une bonne thèse
pour toutes ce type de thèse
alors j'ai pas le plaisir de bien
connaître me l'a en revanche j'ai eu la
chance d'aller souvent à new york
ces bouches d'égout mais ce sont toutes
ses canalisations vous avez new york est
fait sur des marécages et c'est
n'importe quoi de se bouger la chance
d'aller dans les égouts new york c'est
effrayant effrayant vraiment dans le
passé ouais mais ça c'est un peu les
réacs qui dit ça moi je considère que
notre avenir est très sombre mais qu'on
a quand même beaucoup d'avenir
et voilà donc tout va bien moi je suis
pas une sorte moi je suis une sorte de
pessimistes joyeuse un peu pessimiste
festive donc je rêvais estime que tout
est foutu mais je bois du champagne
[Musique]